[Musique]
avec Diane et Nicolas bonsoir à vous
deux bonsoir vous avez suivi les
événements sur les la réunion des
ministres des centres de la santé
ministre de la Santé sur les transferts
sociaux je mentionne tout de suite que
il n'y a pas d'entente et que le
ministre de la Santé de la Colombie
Britannique qui est l'autre de cette
rencontre puisque ça se passe avant
couvert à dit clairement que les
provinces étaient déçues on n'a pas de
chiffres exacts de ce qui est proposé
par le gouvernement fédéral qui dit
autour que certaines conditions qui sont
toujours appliquées si on devait
augmenter les transferts en santé
première réaction d'abord Nicolas
Duvernois on est encore là mais j'allais
dire en blague il était supposé avoir
une entorse il me semble que chaque fois
qu'il
avec l'espoir ok on vit des sports
d'abord et d'eau fraîche mais c'est
éternel c'est comme le jour de la
marmotte c'est un éternel recommencement
il y a le gouverne quand il y a un plan
pas clair net et précis quand il y a pas
une répartition des tâches clairement
été précise mais c'est ça que ça donne
c'est toujours le bordel alors le
fédéral croit qu'il a tel droit le
provincial pourtant les la compétence en
santé pour l'immense majorité le des
besoins disons et de compétences
provinciales mais ça tire toujours la
couverture d'un bas puis de l'autre on
dirait la belle-mère que tu aimes pas
trop qui s'incruste dans la dans une
dispute de couple le fédéral veut
toujours mettre son nez à droite à
gauche poser des conditions et de
l'autre côté ben le provincial c'est un
peu la dose qui dépense beaucoup là puis
qui veut qui a besoin départ exactement
qui va être aidé parce qu'il se retrouve
un peu dans la merde faut payer le
minimum la carte de crédit par le
fédéral c'est éternel c'est épuisant
mais ces problématiques aussi parce que
on parle de pour tout le Canada de
centaines de milliards dollars parce
qu'on parle oui peut-être 45 milliards
que de retour du fédéral mais toutes les
provinces dépensent des milliards et des
milliards dans la santé puis on est
toujours besoin Nicolas mais on en a
besoin ou parce qu'on dépense malienne
mais moi ce qui me rend mal à l'aise
c'est que c'est la santé donc après ma
barre que les provinces et des pouvoirs
qu'elle puisse les exercer je suis tout
à fait d'accord le problème c'est que je
suis québécoise et que moi-même j'ai un
malaise avec les dépenses québécoises en
santé et avec le budget de la santé qui
augmente et je me pose beaucoup de
questions donc je sais qu'il y a plein
de bons monde sur le terrain que tout le
monde veut bien faire mais est-ce que
j'ai envie de donner un chèque en blanc
et et la demande de réédition de compte
qu'on soit que ce soit que ça vienne de
Québec ou d'Ottawa elle est nécessaire
il faut que le secteur de la santé fasse
une reddition de compte et que des
indicateurs maintenant c'est sûr que
dans si on place ça dans le contexte
d'Ottawa versus les provinces oui il y a
quelque chose d'agaçant dans cette
éternelle rengaine là mais c'est de la
santé dont on
pour la santé on écoute tout de suite
réaction du ministre de la Santé un peu
plus tôt il y a quelques minutes de
Christian Dubé
tout le monde en a le même objectif
c'est de dire au fédéral écouter on peut
on peut faire la job mais en ce moment
on a besoin de votre aide puis on a
besoin de l'avoir sans condition parce
qu'en ce moment nous on attend pas des
conditions on fait des investissements
qui sont souvent au dessus de notre tête
qui sont beaucoup plus importants que ce
qu'on devrait faire et ça nous prend la
différence fédérale
c'est difficile comme citoyen de se dire
et de voir comme on a vu le système de
santé depuis deux ans vivre ce qu'il a
vécu voir et entendre parler de
conditions qui sont essentielles au
fonctionnement de la fédération mais ce
qui manque de l'argent c'est du bide ben
non on fait quand même les
investissements mais oui on a quand même
besoin d'argent alors on fait la job ça
c'est la phrase de la clip et je dis
tout de suite je crois que Monsieur Dubé
fait une job exceptionnelle en tant que
ministre de la Santé un des meilleurs de
ce que je peux me rappeler cependant
est-ce qu'on fait la job historiquement
2008 on a dépensé pour le réseau de la
santé 24 milliards au Québec 15 ans plus
tard on a plus que doublé 51 milliards
donc toi tu dis hey c'est sûr que plein
de nouveaux hôpitaux et les CHSLD c'est
la Cadillac pour nos aînés c'est clair
et net qu'il y a pas d'attente dans les
urgences c'est clair et net que les
infirmières et les les employés
d'entretien et tout ça ont des bonnes
conditions ne s'améliorent mais non
détériore
objectifs il y a un vieillissement de la
population mais moi il y a une seule
question qui me hante à propos du
secteur de la santé puis j'aimerais ça
que la refondation du ministre du bébé
répond à cette question là pourquoi le
quand on parle de santé l'État est
considéré comme un mauvais employeur que
l'on fuit alors c'est les infirmières
fuiles secteur de la santé les
psychologues puis le secteur de santé on
va aller au privé moi ce que je voudrais
c'est cette réponse là que le secteur de
la santé soit un bon employable que les
meilleurs éléments y travaillent est-ce
qu'on peut demander de l'argent
supplémentaire à Ottawa si on baisse les
impôts non ça a aucun sens c'est c'est
irrationnel tout l'argent qu'on a donné
en mai et en décembre on parle de 7
milliards donc puis là on met des bases
d'impôts dans les prochaines années
27 donc à quelque part faut être
crédible et cohérent quand on va
négocier avec Ottawa mais ça démontre la
limite ou l'incohérence de la manière
dont le pays et est bâti et je sors
l'idée s'ouvreuse ou pas mais c'est
juste que c'est un bordel notoire quand
euh le fédéral vient chercher de
l'argent dans les poches du provinceau
en quelque sorte qu'on paye les impôts
et puis par la suite le provincial doit
gérer plus ou moins la province puis
ensuite retourner au fédéral pour
redemander de l'argent et elle l'a là
c'est vraiment casse-tête c'est très
complexe je crois pas qu'on peut
répondre rapidement et facilement à des
grosses situations comme ça mais c'est
sûr que il va falloir des changements
drastiques parce qu'on flotte on flotte
c'est le terme exact des milliards et
des milliards de dollars dans la santé
entre la Fédérale puis provincial il y a
le fait qu'on a fait cadeau de 7
milliards à des gens qui n'avaient pas
nécessairement besoin pour ça a augmenté
l'inflation puis après on se retourne
qui ont deux fédérales on a besoin
d'argent pour le système de santé qui
craque de partout faut quand même être
cohérent ok je vous amène sur un autre
sujet il nous reste quelques minutes le
nu à déposer aujourd'hui en marge de la
cop27 qui se déroule en Égypte un
rapport présidé par l'ancienne ministre
de l'Environnement Catherine McKenna qui
dit que les promesses vertes des
entreprises des banques et des villes ne
sont souvent que de l'écho blanche
blanchiment et qu'il faut arrêter de
dire qu'on va être carbonate et qu'on
est carbonate qu'on a des objectifs il
faut que ça paraisse réellement parce
que beaucoup de ces entreprises qui
continuent dans le fond d'investir dans
des projets fossiles où il y a des
émissions de gaz à effet de serre votre
réaction d'abord
la qualité c'est une idée beaucoup trop
réaliste alors tu équation alors à
gauche on a on baisse les émissions de
gaz à effet de serre on ajoute une autre
partie d'équation c'est pendant qu'on
les baisse tout doucement tranquillement
à notre rythme on fait de la captation
donc on plante des arbres pour pour
capter les GES on prend la technologie
puis tout ça ça fait zéro au bout de la
ligne mais là non parce que la partie de
l'équation à droite on l'a à gauche on
l'a pas fait donc les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre ont augmenté de 60%
depuis 1990 à la grandeur de la planète
donc si la partie gauche fonctionne pas
on peut pas avoir de carbone neutralité
c'est simple comme ça est-ce que les
entreprises font de l'écho blanchement
Nicolas non seulement ça juste pour vous
dire les le milliards d'arbres promis
aussi par le gouvernement Trudeau il y a
5-6 ans on attend encore
est-ce que les entreprises font des
gouvernements ça c'est exactement le
syndrome quand on mélange fake news et
marketing et les entreprises certaines
entreprises font de l'écho blanchiment
mais ils disent qu'ils sont bio quand
ils sont pas bio il suffit d'aller sur
une certaine plateforme pour voir des
produits du Québec qui sont faites à
Taïwan il suffit de regarder les
entreprises qui se disent bicarpe mais
qui produisent des chaussures en taille
en Thaïlande ou au Vietnam on fait quoi
pour améliorer ça alors le langage
monétaire est souvent tristement le seul
langage compris par les entreprises qui
jouent les cowboys donc on se met des on
met des règles extrêmement difficiles en
quelque sorte ou extrêmement
contraignantes pour être sûr que c'est
celui qui dit qu'il sauve la planète
soit vraiment la planète et on met des
pénalités financières que certaines
directives mais moi je dis soyons tu es
quelqu'un qui ment là je paye c'est un
moment donné
j'aurais répondu pour Nicolas comme
Nicolas mais pas aujourd'hui non
aujourd'hui on réalise
penser ceux qui font bien le bâton
fonctionne pas parce qu'il fera son
marché
à ceux qui font bien et les autres il
faut qu'ils voient qu'ils auront rien
parce que à quelque part de toute façon
le bâton il frappe pas fort on sait très
bien que le marché du carbone la donne
n'est pas assez élevé de toute façon le
prix en ce moment fonctionne pas mais le
bâton à 200$
[Musique]
merci bonne soirée